this is insane to get this canoe
up and over this rock ledge with time
running out on day four of this million
dollar marathon
team north america is up against the
wall
the intensity is uh is at an all-time
high
we don't want to make a mistake here the
day has just thrown
everything at us for the last 24 hours
the co-workers from denver have
exhausted themselves hauling
and rowing a 50-pound canoe through the
dense thickness
and fierce currents of the ontario
wetlands
if they can't muscle up and over a final
cliff they'll find themselves
tumbling down the scoreboard we're so
close to the end of this day i can feel
it and now all of a sudden we're like
not moving and yesterday we didn't get
any points
if we're missing even one point it could
be the difference between first and
third place
i think i can climb up this if you guys
can
push we can get this thing up here right
ready hold it under
you can hold it
[Music]
this is nuts oh my god even happy
i know if we get through this next pitch
we're good
this one looks pretty gnar this is crazy
you're so vertical
all right
turn around and just look how far up we
just carried a canoe
that's insane you guys yeah
all right down the road up the road i
think we got to go up the road guys
you guys i see trucks
are you frank oh i'm
finally clear of the wetlands the crew
was rewarded with one hard-earned point
and a nice warm car ride to winnipeg ah
happy thanksgiving yeah you too
you must be canadian i am now i might as
well be
today's pretosha was a totally different
level
and it's hard to say in retrospect if we
would have done things differently
thank you frank i mean this is the kind
of race where
you have a gps and you have a situation
and circumstances are such that
you you make a decision as a team and
you run with it
is there a bear behind me there's a bear
there's a bear on top of the trash can
behind me
it's an acrobatic bear
what's he gonna do
[Music]
okay now there's deer coming up in my
interview by the way anyway back
back in kenora
[Music]
you